welcome to this five-minute blitz game
for some reason I had the bra totally
distorted so I lost the couple of
seconds here in the outset of this video
play a guy from the Netherlands right
IAM called in a few minutes and he's
friendly enough to also he was 16
seconds for move one so let's see
probably an Enzo I don't want to play
the same ish again I mean I want to but
ok we don't even get an Enzo ok someone
is messaging me and he's saying hello
Christophe maybe I know the guy possible
playing for in the Netherlands for a
long time so it's possible that I know
him ok we get a modern benoni i'm
playing with 92 93 good text in there no
yeah this line i have used number of
times already on video with quite good
results it fortifies the for porn make
sure it is nicely protected yeah this is
the only big argument against it or not
a big argument but the only thing that
black can try to to do to really use
this night on g3 ok I don't mind to
prevent age for for a moment so maybe
queen bee sixes a month now hmm like a
queen bee six ok it's not doing that ok
a four I like to play that would really
like to get in Queen d2 bishan age 6
this is really a very nice if possible
castles arm Queen d2 first I guess I
guess castles yeah when I move like
Queen B 6 there is maybe even a five the
reason why I keep talking about cream be
sixes what I don't want to do is to to
allow on something like night h7 Bishop
back and h4 okay maybe I get in Bishop
age six now very nice okay but Bishop
age 60 might play h4 so should I player
3 make sure that if I was protected
maybe I should by now black has played
moves like b6 especially be success not
really helpful and now Bishop age 6 h-4
I can just safely go to h1 I could play
a fourth just ticking this this piece
f 494 h3 is certainly good for white
therefore you will probably need to go
back to the seven and then I also have
at five maybe do that this mrs. salts
are quite dangerous I know it gives up
the five square but it also initiates a
direct attack a g6 is weakened this
becomes interesting this plan with black
having played h5 the palm would be on h
seventh and f4 f5 is really far less
attractive here this is debatable of it
is such a great plan but i think it's
interesting yes yeah what i want to do
is I want to make sure that he cannot
easily put a night only five I wonder I
wonder how to do this ideally hmm many
possibilities but probably just our
bishop age six now yeah taking and
Bishop age six probably if he goes age
for now I can take g7 and maybe even
play Knight f5 that's at least an
interesting sacrifice probably probably
it's a good sacrifice and not so easy
but it's tricky for black now if he
wants to preserve the bishop with the
new flag bishop age a delicate Queen g5
coming
it's very dangerous
hmm that's a dangerous position from
black and he is getting low on time I
mean I wasn't playing very quickly but
black is slower yes hmm this I
underestimated I misunderestimated
George W Bush court um what to do here
Queen g5 this night h7 now this is not
really helping so should I just double
on the FR but that's Nyjah for right
sorry hmm hmm that's not great
I didn't play that very well night h7s I
as an issue on Queen g5 Andrew gave two
in-service night g-form not grade okay
maybe take a Droog f form yeah this
didn't this didn't really work out well
he can just play Bishop d7 Andrew gave
aid it's not dramatically bad for me oh
this is Sir this is helpful i guess
night f5 quite surprising now i get some
play against g5 that's that's that's
dangerous their file I cannot even
protect them the night yeah g5 for the
bad move I guess
the neighbors doorbell a sound that
really can be very scary at times very
annoying sound okay night sorry rook f7
or take you first taking first is
probably the simplest now it's got queen
d 4 so that after takings he takes maybe
the e4 pawn gets lost okay why would
have let Queen f2 yeah I can just cash
in check check check oops black resigned
yeah that was a bit of a lucky win
really lucky win yeah i was i was lucky
that he played g5 other than that i'm
not in a good shape if blackler just
plays Bishop d7 here for example rook f1
okay wait I think this is really what
black wants to achieve he's got those
good nights especially b5 it's not so
easy for black Joe to get anything
concrete going but black is certainty is
somewhat better here the problem with
this kind of move like f5 is you need to
get something concrete other than that
it's not I can play if I there five this
typical maneuver that's better yeah I
thought why not play it instantly there
is this this type of sacrifice which I
have played often enough on video but
this time I thought I can also play it
without giving away the pawn okay what's
my problem this is this is not really
great iam or it is okay but I need to
play e5 here if I've is also an
interesting move him this idea with
Bishop d3 I didn't want to sacrifice
something but here I'm ending up with a
position where my
direct dynamic play is simply not not
dangerous anymore Queen F for us and
also interesting this being an important
point with wide winning you had the play
that well I need to do something
something more direct also this was good
attacking this week pawn and the move
like King edge seven I don't know this
probably shouldn't end well hmm computer
gives a funky line age for Luke a
seven-night age 59 age five Bishop g6
yeah this this type of line is certainly
working the very very big attack yeah I
didn't play that well but he helped me
with g5 and the g5 move immediately
turns turns the table he could have
played Queen g6 though it's a bit
tougher idea what is just immediately
winning with those two nights being in
this in this terrible f file alright
thanks for watching